name a quirky lovable scientist who
wears a bowtie with his lab coat you're
probably picturing Bill Nye but I'm
actually talking about this guy
Leo petrochemicals are used to make
products that you use every day wait
here playbook whoo products like aspirin
holding earbuds
unlike Bill Nye leo is funded by the oil
and gas industry and his goal is to
persuade young kids to see big oil
positively he's just one tool Big Oil is
using to influence the public school
system in places like Oklahoma and Ohio
they're only talking really about oil
and gas how beneficial it is but what's
missing from that is sort of the
downsides of petroleum hey guys I'm
stream and today we've partnered with
the Center for Public Integrity to bring
you a story about how the school
curriculum is being developed by oil and
gas interests you see Oklahoma oil and
natural gas can be used to make
thousands of things we use in our homes
schools and businesses daily but only
once refined its engaging right can you
imagine being a fifth grader and your
teacher uses this as a science lesson
that's exactly what's happening in
Oklahoma
Jenny Zhao a reporter for the Center for
Public Integrity and Joe Wirtz of state
impact Oklahoma spoke to teachers opting
to get their lesson plans from some not
so neutral sources you kind of look at
climate change understanding as it
exists today how to become so
politically polarized and I think this
story kind of gives you insight into why
kids might have such mixed messages on
climate change itself this story is also
really fascinating because of the range
of profile materials and how many
teachers are using them that Bill Nye
knock-off I showed you earlier lab time
with Leo has been used by 11,000
educators in their classrooms the
industries even developed materials for
super young students Petra Pete's
adventure is aimed at the kindergarten
crowd telling kids they wouldn't be able
to brush their teeth without petroleum
products here's the background oil and
gas is big business in Oklahoma so big
in fact it's hard to sum up in just one
number
they spend five billion to pay
thousands of employees and ten billion
on building wells and there's a whole
bunch of secondary spending also worth
billions
that's all in just one year meanwhile
the Oklahoma school system is broke in
state officials cut more than 30 million
dollars in the public school budget that
led to school closures layoffs and
cutting classes to only four days a week
in some schools
I made these tough times educators are
turning to the Oklahoma Energy Resources
Board for supplies that's the oil funded
organization that created Leo and Petro
Pete it's great that they want to go out
and help teachers I have to provide
pretty much all my materials for myself
and for my classroom and to get $300
worth of tape for free is fantastic and
they've spent nearly 40 million since
1996 on afterschool programs curriculum
and other educational resources they
also sponsor petroleum related field
trips and reimburse teachers for
supplies that's a big deal since a lot
of teachers spent hundreds of dollars of
their own money on students and a few
hundred dollars really counts in
Oklahoma where teacher salaries are
among the lowest in the nation lawmakers
decided to continue giving Big Oil 470
million in tax breaks
despite the school budget shortfall and
it's not just Oklahoma in Ohio the oil
and gas industry has been sponsoring
teacher field trips on key issues like
fracking all I knew about fracking was
what was in the media
in media and what I've known so far
seems very skewed from what it is
according to their website the Ohio oil
and gas energy education program also
sponsors teacher workshops scholarships
and science fairs in Saline ve'lo high
oh they've gone a step further by
supporting a public charter school where
students are drilling certifications oil
and gas play a big role in the lessons
taught at this publicly funded school
why does this matter
well besides five year olds being highly
impressionable this raises bigger
questions about whether we should be
allowing corporations in the classroom
at all and it's a bit of a legal gray
area decisions about what gets taught in
schools are made largely at the state
and district levels the federal
government has little involvement which
means there's an opportunity for
companies to write lessons that reflect
their agenda this is also important
because it's happening in classrooms
where students may not definitively hear
that climate change is man-made and it
is in Oklahoma lawmakers have been
pushing to loosen science standards
especially on global warming meanwhile
the oil funded organizations writing
these books and lesson plans are
misleading about their role in climate
change the Ohio oil and gas energy
education program on the same website
where they post lesson plans for
teachers also repost articles with
headlines like this fossil fuels have
made the earth cleaner not dirtier which
is not true and their environmental fact
sheet highlights how fracking adds water
to the planet it doesn't
the average fracking well uses over 2
million gallons of water and bizarrely
that same fact sheet claims that crude
oil and natural gas are the first
alternative fuels and save whales from
extinction alternative fuels is a term
often used to describe green energy so
it's use in this context is misleading
as for the Oklahoma Energy Resources
Board they just avoid using the term
climate change altogether but this
information is not isolated to Oklahoma
and Ohio a similar organization the
national energy education development
project created materials to roll out
nationwide a 2014 packet published by
the group teaches students that some
scientists think it's too soon to tell
if the earth is really warming and a
little warming might be a good thing for
the earth need is funded by Energy
Giants BP Shell and dozens of
corporations who want to get kids early
so what do you need to know about the
oil industry
it's in your car plastics and even your
classrooms hey thanks for watching we
were really lucky to partner with the
Center for Public Integrity to bring you
this fascinating research don't forget
to Like subscribe and share